welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and while we sit
on the edges of our seats to find out
who exactly is a scroll and who may or
may not be dead I thought it'd be a
perfect time to trace the origins of
these secret Invaders all the way back
to their Homeworld there's clearly some
internal conflict in a deep cultural
shame that a handful of Scrolls seem to
have on the subject so today we're gonna
dive into the comics to find out the
truth as to what might happen to
scrollos in the MCU you can enter to win
a free hopsco e-bike just by subscribing
to our new channel the break room click
the link in this video's description
before July 23rd to enter we first met
the Scrolls in Captain Marvel which was
set in the totally tubular 90s while the
shapeshifters don't shy away from lure
and Cree forces into death traps their
violence is primarily a necessity to
escape the Creed that are hell-bent on
the complete genocide of their people by
the end of the film we learned that the
skrulls are just refugees looking for a
place to call their home as we move into
secret Invasion however we're slowly
finding out that the scroll situation
isn't as black and white as we thought
the cree and the scroll War has a long
history and there's blood on the hands
of both sides in the second episode of
secret Invasion Fury pointedly asks
Talos about the downfall of the skull's
home planet skrullos and Talos Dodges
the question now this scene is mostly
used to reveal that a million or so
sprawls are hiding on Earth but it does
also seem like Talos is glossing over
some pretty important key details about
The Showdown on skrullos later in the
episode The Scroll that goes by Shirley
tells gravic's coup that they all ended
up homeless refugees because they were
too willing to wage war seemingly
confirming that Talos was skirting
around a larger truth about the downfall
of skrillos so what exactly happened
what hand did the skrulls play in their
own downfall the comics tell us that the
skrulls may have actually started the
cree scroll war and that just like
humans the squirrels have a complicated
and blood-stained history of their own
so let's rewind back to the dawn of
skrulls hundreds of millions of years
ago nestled within the Andromeda galaxy
lies the planet skrullos and much like
Earth the celestials took an interest in
this planet these Cosmic entities
experimented on the native reptilian
species creating three brand of scroll
subgroups scroll eternals deviant
Scrolls and Prime Scrolls Prime Scrolls
aka the normal Scrolls held no
exceptional Powers but Eternal Scrolls
had Cosmic superpowers much like our
eternals and the Deviant skrulls
developed the ability to shapeshift from
across the Stars Tantalus the leader of
another deviant race called upon
deviance to overthrow their counterparts
and the Deviant skrulls took their
advice and started Waging War on their
genetic cousins crime and eternal
Scrolls were eradicated in a genocide
and the Deviant Scrolls became the
forefathers of the modern scroll the
Scrolls then became a wide sprawling
technologically advanced Empire that
colonized the Galaxy One Planet they
aimed to colonize was the cree Homeworld
of hala hala was actually home to two
dominant sentient species the cree and
the plant-based katati for some reason
the squirrels could only put down one
species on their Galactic partnership
registration form so they pitted the two
races against each other each species
was given a blank planet for 17 of their
best Minds to inhabit and the group that
brought the planet the farthest within a
year would win gaining representation
with the Scrolls and access to their
Advanced Tech basically scroll Emperor
Doric the first was like show me what
you've got and sent the cree out to play
a game of civilization McCree Minds the
planet to build a city while the kotati
communed with nature and built luscious
Gardens sensing that the Scrolls would
favor the kotati the cree turned their
efforts towards eliminating their
competition by force well technically it
was full on genocide which clearly seems
to be a big theme Here luckily a few
kotafi seeds survived and their species
was eventually able to repopulate when
skrull Emperor Doric the first returned
he was shocked by the cree's violence
the cree seized this opportunity to slay
the emperor and take the skrull's
technology for themselves this was the
Catalyst for the rise of the cree Empire
and the start of the Rivalry that
fashioned both species into ruthless
Warriors unfortunately due to the
distance between both Empires this would
be exacerbated into a million year long
War as generation after generation would
use resources to take pot shots at one
another but wouldn't have the resources
to win the conflict while it does seem
like the Creed through the first punch
here it should be noted that it's sort
of messed up that the Scrolls pit the
inhabitants of holla against each other
in a fight for Supremacy especially when
you consider their own history with
genocide e-biking is a fun new form of
transportation that's a perfect match
for a fun New YouTube channel the break
room our friends at hopsco make the best
e-bikes hopsco e-bike can go up to 28
miles per hour with pedal assist with a
range of up to 60 miles without ever
needing to pump your legs which is great
because I am lazy we have hopsco e-bikes
of the new Rockstar's office and we love
them we're doing a special promotion
with hopsco that will let one lucky
viewer win a hopsco e-bike for free all
you have to do is support our channel
the break room you want to do that
anyways because it's got great daily
content including inside Marvel
reactions after shows and breaking news
just click the link in the description
below to get started sign up for
hopsco's giveaway and then subscribe to
the break room on YouTube or twitch the
link in the description below has all
the details you need on how to maximize
your chance of winning a hopsco e-bike
do it before July 23rd so you don't miss
out so what happened to scrollos over
the course of the last million years in
the unending War well in the comics
skrillos is still kicking it and makes a
rare appearance from time to time but it
should be noted that it wasn't the
capital planet of the Scrolls for most
of their history pretty much directly
after the Deviant Scrolls started their
empire they moved shop to Tarn X4 AKA
Throne World tarnax floor like scrollos
in the MCU is no longer around which
makes me think that the MCU might be
drawing some inspiration from this piece
of the comics surprisingly tarnax 4
wasn't destroyed due to Cree opposition
but to the big Baddie Galactus due to
the skrull's feud with Earth they'd
kidnapped and experimented on several of
its Heroes the heroes in obvious comic
book fashion would escape and once they
did they'd get the coordinates to throne
World in a bid to save Earth from
Galactus his Herald Frankie Ray AKA Nova
use the information she gleaned from
Reed Richards to bring him to tarnax
four damn girl that is one fresh meal
for the Devourer so how did the
celestials cree and Galactus all come
together for the mcu's version of
skrillos here's my rogue Theory we know
that a big theme of Secret invasion is
cyclical nature of war and power species
themselves be the human skrull or Cree
aren't inherently good or evil some sex
choose peace and others choose violence
or power the Scrolls have been drawn to
war in the past and according to surely
their magnetism to war is what caused
the downfall of skrillos I think we
might be looking at hints of the skrulls
having developed a weapon akin to the
atomic bomb a weapon that could end
their war with decree but a Pandora's
Box that could end the universe and all
life as well we know from the comics
that skrillos had their own eternals and
deviance conflict and this coincides
nicely with the introduction of the
concept of celestials in the MCU so you
know how the eternals were caught in a
cycle of stewarding civilizations only
to wipe them out by hatching a big old
Celestial baby right through the core of
the planet yeah that was likely the plan
on scrollos as well but the scroll
deviants beat their eternals and thus
the process of emerging the celestial
beneath strelose never occurred deviance
hate celestials so presumably they could
figure out how to actively prevent one
from hatching but all that energy
potential is still there waiting beneath
the surface absorbing a million year old
Empire's power that's a form of cosmic
energy that the squirrels may have
thought to tap into to defeat the Creed
that's right baby scroll Oppenheimer
might be coming to the MCU by
weaponizing their Celestial the skrull
Empire could have forced the cree empire
into destroying scrollos before they
could fire up their God power death beam
to me this is a likely scenario but
depending on how wants to roll out
mcu's big bads I'm wondering if there's
a more tragic alternative instead of the
cree destroying skrillos the energy
emitted from their Celestial weapon
could have drawn the attention of
Galactus just like the way Galactus was
brought to throne world as a result of
the skrull's attempts to destroy Earth
the Scrolls attempts to destroy the
Creed could have drawn in a force beyond
their comprehension to add insult to
injury in comic Cannon Galactus is so
powerful that mortals can only
comprehend their Visage by appearing as
a member of their species so humans see
Galactus is a big Baldi but skrulls
would see them as a massive scroll A
fitting image for a species that's
bloodlust inadvertently brought about
the destruction of their own Homeworld
something shameful that Hallows doesn't
feel is worth sharing with Fury just yet
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Whitney puppy follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]